in the last video we saw a little bit
more formally than you might have been
exposed to in the past that a function
is just a mapping
of the members of one set to another set
so this is my first set x we call that
the domain
and the set that we're mapping to y in
this case that's called the codomain and
the function just maps each of the
specific entries of x
to an entry in y when i say map it
really just creates an association you
could if we think of these in very maybe
maybe even less abstract terms but on
some levels it's more abstract you could
view x as a basket of bananas and y is a
basket of apples and for every banana
you're associating it with one of the
apples though that would be a
the the definition the mapping of going
from each of those bananas to each of
those apples would be a function i don't
know if that helps you or not but i just
want to kind of broaden your your
already your kind of preconceived
notion of what a function is i mean
everything that you've probably seen
before probably took something
took a form that looked something like
that where you said oh a function you
just give me some number and i'll give
you another number or i'll do something
to that number while it can be much more
general that it's association between
any member of one set and some other
members of another set now we know that
vectors are members of sets
right vectors
in particular if we say that some vector
if we say that some vector x is a member
of some set let me just say it's a
member of rn
because that's what we deal with all
that means is that this is just a
particular representation of an n tuple
remember what r n was let me
r n we defined way back i think maybe i
don't know at the beginning of the
linear algebra playlist we defined it
as the set of all n tuples
n tuples
you know x1
x2
xn
where your x1s x2s all the way to xn's
are a member of the real numbers
so your rn is most definitely a set this
could be rn and obviously the use of the
letter n is arbitrary it could be rm it
could be rs n is just kind of a
placeholder for how many tuples we have
this could be r5 it could be five tuples
and when we say that a vector x is a
member of rn we're just saying that it's
it's another way of writing one of these
n tuples and all of our vectors so far
were our column vectors that's the only
type that we've defined so far and we
say it's this ordered list where each of
the members are member of r it's an
ordered list of n
it's an ordered list of n components
x1 x2 all the way to xn where each of
those guys were each of those x1s x2s
all the way to xns are a member of
the real numbers that's by definition
what we mean when we say that x is a
member of rn so if x is a member of rn
so let me
let me draw two sets right here let's
say that this set right here is
r
n
and then let me just change
just to be general let me create another
set right there and call that
call that set right there rm just a
different number it could be the same as
n it could be different this is m tuples
that's n tuples
we could the vectors we've defined that
vectors can be members of rn so you
could have some vector here
you could have some vector here and then
if you associate with that vector in r m
if you associate it with some vector in
r m
if you associate it with and let's call
that vector let's call that vector y
if you make this association
that 2 is a function and that might have
already been obvious to you and you know
this would be a function that's mapping
from r
n
to
r
m and actually i just want to make one
little special note here when i just do
the arrow like this this shows that i'm
mapping between two sets i'm taking
elements of this set and i'm associating
with them elements of that set now in
the last video you probably saw this i
want to do the side note because i
thought i realized it might have been
confusing i introduced you another way
of writing a function like this
where i said f could be
defined as
a mapping for any given x
to
x squared and i just want to make a note
on the notation when i just have a
regular arrow i'm going between sets
when i have
when i have this little
vertical line at the at the base of the
arrow that's kind of the function
definition it tells me for any x
you give me in the first set
in the second set i'm going to associate
this x with in this case x squared
anyway i just wanted to make that side
note but the whole i guess direction i
was going in is that vectors are valid
elements of sets functions are just
mappings between elements of sets so you
could have functions of vectors
and i even touched on that in a little
bit in the last video when i talked
about vector valued functions if your
codomain
if your codomain
is a subset of if your codomain is a
subset
of r
m
where m is greater than one then we say
your function is vector valued it's
going to it's not just mapping into the
real numbers it's mapping into some
set of real well let me say some
m tuple of real numbers so if you mapped
you know to two dimensional space you're
dealing with a vector valued function
now i've been all abstract and whatnot
so let me actually deal with some
vectors and it might make everything a
little bit more concrete so let's say i
define the function f
i define the function f as f of
x 1
x 2
and x 3
is equal to
let's say it's equal to x one
plus two x two
and
the second coordinate is just three
x three and actually haven't formally
defined coordinates for you yet but i
think you understand that just from your
basic
algebra training so let's say that
that's my function definition
based on the notation that we've been
introduced to we can say that f is a
mapping from
it's a mapping its domain is r3 and it
maps from r3 or it associates all values
in r3 with some value in r2
and r2 right this is a 2-tuple
this is a 2-tuple
right so this is an r2 this is a three
tuple
three tuple
right or another way we could do this if
we just wanted to write it in vector
notation
i could write
that
f
if you pass f
to f some vector
x 1
x 2
x 3
i could say this will be equal to the
vector and now it's going to have a 2
component vector it's going to be a
vector in r two where the first term is
x one
plus two x two and the second term is
three
x three so let's play around with this a
little bit see what it what it does
forced what it does to the vectors so
what is
f of
let me do a simple one
of the vector 1
well i get
let's see 1 plus 2 times 1 plus 2 times
1 is i get the vector 3
and then my second term is just 3 times
this one so i get the vector 3
3.
fair enough let me do another one just
just just to really experiment with this
with this mapping
if i get if i take
the f of
the vector in r 3 2
what do i get
that equals c
2 plus 2 times 4 that goes to the vector
right 2
plus 2 times 4 and then 3 times the
the third term right there so the vector
3. so how can we visualize this how can
we visualize this well three-dimensional
vectors or our vectors in r3 are not
always the easiest to visualize but i
think we can attempt to
visualize these two guys
let's
see
so the first
the first let me do it a little bit
better than that
so let's say that this is the
let's say this is the x1 axis that's the
x2 axis that's the x3 axis
so this first vector right here this
yellow one one one one will look like
this
one
one and so if i were to go out here then
go out here and go up one the point
would be right there and if i were to
draw it in standard position i'd start
at the origin and the vector looks
something like that and then the second
guy 2 4 1 it would look like this
it would be we'd go 2 out here
we'd go 4 in this direction 1 2 3 4 and
then we'd go 1 up so it looks something
like this
2 4 1. i think you get the idea
you get the idea so that i've drawn
these two vectors these two vectors that
are essentially in my domain our domain
is r3 right this is r3 right here
and let's see what our function maps
these vectors to so the the it maps
what's our codomain our codomain is r2
so this is much easier to visualize for
us
so we just have to draw
two axes
we just have to draw two axes like this
let's call this x one and let's call
this x two and so what does f of one one
one of this yellow vector it becomes
three three so if i do it in yellow
one two three
one two three so it gets me this one if
i draw in standard position the vector
looks like
this so we literally our function went
from mapped from this vector in r3
to this vector in r2
that was what our function did
likewise if we take the other vector we
went from this 2 4 1 vector to this
vector 10 3. so 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 10. so it's going to look
something like this it's going to be 3
up
so it's going to look something like
this
so this vector right here by our
function f
got mapped let me do a different color
got mapped to this
vector this vector right here in r3 got
mapped to this vector in r2 by our
function
now this is just a kind of a switch of
terminology when we talk about functions
of vectors the term that we tend to use
is the word transformation
transformation transformation
but it really is the exact same thing as
a function i don't want to confuse you
because if you've watched the
differential equations playlist you saw
the idea of a laplace transformation
which is really an operation that takes
a function as an argument but in this
case and when we're dealing in the
linear algebra world a transformation is
really just a function operating on
vectors or the way we're going to use it
it's just a function operating on
vectors
function
operating
on
vectors
and so the general notation instead of
writing a lowercase f like that we
instead of
for a function people use an uppercase t
to say it's a transformation although it
doesn't have to be an uppercase t but
that's the one that people use the most
just like this could be a g or an h but
people always use the lowercase f so the
same way we could have written this we
could have called this
we could have called this a
transformation and i you know my sense
of why in the linear algebra world they
use this is because you kind of imagine
that this vector is being changed into
that vector or that this vector is being
transformed into that vector i think
that's why they call it a transformation
as opposed to a function actually makes
a lot more sense when you start going
into things like you know video game
programming and a lot of what we're
embarking on with our transformations is
key to linear to video game programming
but you're kind of transforming one
image into another image if you're
viewing it from a different angle or
or whatever else you might want to do
we'll talk a lot more about that in the
future but i just want to introduce you
this notation so these these
statements could have i could have just
as easily written my i could have
replaced all my f's with ts and i could
have defined some transformation and i
just want to make you comfortable with
the notation i could have defined it
similarly a transformation from
r 3
to
r 2
r 3 to r 2 and i could have said that t
of x 1 x 2 x 3
is equal to
the two tuple
x 1 plus 2 x 1 comma 3
x 3
and i could have just a similarly i
could have put a t up here because i've
defined it the same way i could have
said t of
my vector 1 1 1
is equal to 3 3. now you might say hey
sal why are you going through all this
trouble of you know replacing t's with
us i'm just doing this so you don't get
confused so that when you see when you
know in your linear algebra book when
you see linear algebra problems where
you see this big capital t and you're
like well i've never seen that before
and they're using this fancy word called
a transformation this is completely
identical to your notion of a function
it is a function in the next video i'm
going to talk about linear
transformations that's really just
linear functions and i'll define that a
little bit more precisely in the next
video but hopefully by you know by
watching this video you at least have a
sense that you can apply functions to
vectors and in the linear algebra world
we tend to call those transformations
and hopefully this example right here
gives you at least a visual
representation of why it's called a
transformation we're transforming from
one vector to another